El perímetro del jardín de Erwing mide 60 metros.
Si lo largo del jardín mide 2 veces lo ancho del jardín,
¿cuáles son las dimensiones del jardín?
Ok, entonces Erwing tiene un jardín...
vamos a dibujarlo por acá...
esto es lo ancho del jardín y no sabemos cuanto mide, por lo cual, vamos a decir que mide "w" metros.
Lo que sí sabemos es que lo largo del jardín,
mide 2 veces lo ancho del jardín,
pero lo ancho del jardín estamos diciendo ahorita
que vale "w",
por lo cual aquí tenemos que poner "w".
Ok, esto es otra vez lo ancho del jardín,
entonces mide "w" y esto lo largo del jardín,
así es que mide, 2 veces lo ancho del jardín,
o sea 2 por "w".
Entonces, lo que sabemos nosotros, es que
el perímetro del jardín de Erwing
mide 60 metros, ¿y cómo sacamos el perímetro?
Pues sumamos la longitud de todos los lados
de nuestra figura.
Entonces el perímetro mide...
este lado mide "w", así es que aquí tenemos
que sumar una "w", después "2w"...
"2w"...
más la longitud de este otro lado, que mide "w", más la longitud del último lado que mide "2w",
ok, y eso es igual a, tenemos 1 más 2,
o sea "3w", "4w" y "6w"
el perímetro mide "6w".
Ok, 6 veces lo ancho del jardín, sin embargo
también conocemos la cantidad exacta
de metros que mide el perímetro.
Sí, aquí tenemos que el perímetro del jardín
mide 60 metros, o sea que este perímetro
que sacamos aquí es igual a 60 metros y entonces
nos acabamos de encontrar con una ecuación
con una variable donde nuestra variable es
cuánto mide lo ancho del jardín
y por lo tanto podemos encontrar cuanto tiene que valer
esta variable para que el perímetro sea 60,
como dice el ejercicio que sucede.
Ok, entonces nos queremos deshacer de este
6, por lo que vamos a dividir entre 6
de los dos lados del igual y de esa forma se cancela
este 6 con este 6 y aquí dividimos 60 entre 6,
es igual a 10 y obtenemos que "w"
es igual a 10 y listo.
Entonces "w" es igual a 10, 2 por "w" es igual a 2
por 10, o sea 20, "w" es igual a 10,
2 por "w" es igual a 20...
Y ya tenemos las dimensiones del jardín y
es un jardín de 10 metros por 20 metros.